كيف كنت قادر بصراحه وباختصار ان تصمد كل
هذه السنوات ما الذي كان يعطيك الدافع امل
الخروج
ساقا
وتناولناه في بدايه الحلقه الاولى يعني
انه هناك مجموعه من العوامل
تساعد الانسان على ان
يصمت ولكن بعد اقصد بعد مرور كل ذلك الوقت
لانه نحن شارفنا على الختان يعني نتحدث عن
ثلاثه عشره سنه في النهايات هل يبقى الامل
موجودا هذا ما اقصده الحقيقه مع مرور
الايام يعني
مثل ما بيقولوا باللغه العربيه الفصحى
يغرق في لجنه الياس شيئا فشيئا
ولكن
بالاعماق بالاعماق يعني بضل
باخر النفق في بصيص صغير انه في يومين ما
بدي اطلع اتابع حياتي واتابع مسيري يعني
هذا الامل يبقى موجود يعني وهذا ما فعلته
ولكن كما سمعتك في احدى المقابلات تقول
انه المعتقل يغادر السجن ولكن السجن لا
يغاد لا يغادر لا يغادره ابدا هو معك حتى
الان حتى الان يعني هلا لم يكن بنفس لم
يكن بنفس الحدي غير المقابله لا ولكن
الذكرى او بالتعب النفس حفر هي ندبه
موجوده في النفس الانسانيه تبقى
الانسان عايش فتره احيانا كتير يعني في
البدايات بتطلع من السجن بالبدايه
هاي سميتها حكيت عنها مره انا من اللحظه
هاي اللي بين اليقظه والنوم وانت تكون
نايم
وبدك تفيق من نومك
في هاللحظه هاي يعني بتحس حالك انه انت
بسجن لسه هيك بدك ثانيه او جزء من ثانيه